hello everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i will
hopefully be able to show you in the
time allotted uh how to create your own
custom home page so now a lot of people
have actually noticed this but this is
actually a request by the the first
people actually requested this a lot of
people have seen this as my home page
and actually wondered how i do it so
this is going to be the first part of
the video is going to be how to actually
get the home page and the second part is
actually setting it as your home page in
a number of different web browsers so
i'm going to do first up here well
you've seen my home page in the first
place so i'm going to do is go to
www.shinysearch.com
and that's all you have to type in and
the easiest part here is just selecting
the style you want say i want a
harley-davidson one and select your name
or whatever you want so i'm going to
search bob
and this is bob's custom harley-davidson
homepage there we go so now if he wants
to set this as his homepage right there
you see a set as homepage button however
this does not work with all web browsers
so i'm going to first show you how to do
it in safari this will work on windows
or a mac os 10 go to edit
preferences
and stick under the generals tab
and here you will set current page as
your homepage just hit that set to
current page button and you're good
so whenever i hit that home button it'll
go back to my google search and yes this
is a google search engine by the way
so
also over here you have a few little
options they didn't just have it that
one google page you can also have a
couple of numerous options here for
connecting feeding me meeting your
friends sorry on facebook myspace etc
and more
and you can obviously always exit out of
this with the little x button up here
and if it works i'm guessing it's not
going to work in safari but there you go
so if i wanted to set that as my
homepage for firefox i'm just going to
copy this url which will work in any ip
address and anyone's anyone who happens
to have an internet connection and i'm
going to open up firefox now i do
actually like the firefox homepage
though it does tend to make it crash a
little bit some go up here and just
control v to paste it hit enter and here
is my new homepage now if i want to set
this as my home page i'm going i'm
pretty sure i go to edit now i go to
file
actually it'll be easier if i just right
click on the home page button hit
customize
and this is how you change the toolbar
so that's obviously not it but anyway if
i want to set this as my custom homepage
for firefox that means whenever i would
hit the home page button it would change
and it would load firefox and it would
load i'm sorry this web page right here
so that and i'll also show you i guess
reluctantly enough an internet explorer
how to change your home page now the uh
the url is still in my clipboard so i
don't have to copy and paste it again
so here's internet explorer and my
custom home page right now is just a
blank home page so it's nothing special
so once this is downloading i'll just
hit control v and enter again to get to
this website
and once it loads you can see now here i
had to use that as well
as my home page i would go to the tools
button and go to internet options which
will pop up a new window
and in this window you can choose your
home page now i will just go control v
to paste my home page or if i don't i'll
just see use blank as my home page and
that's it
so that is how you change in internet
explorer and safari and i'll get back to
you on firefox but if you do know go
ahead and leave it in the comments and
that is just about it so that is
now you guys know exactly how i got my
youtube or my uh my custom homepage
whenever i open up safari to be this
little cool lamborghini icon or ferrari
icon so that's basically it if you have
any other tutorials for me just send me
a request and make sure you've
subscribed and the channel that actually
subscribed this video is in the
description thanks for watching guys
peace